if you want to adjust a watchband it's
really easy all you need is a kit like
this one from Tokyo flash and a pair of
pliers you don't even need the kit you
can also do this with a push pin and a
hammer the awesome thing about this kit
is it comes from Japan hammer little
thing for putting your watch band in and
these little tools that look like
needles for shooting up illicit
substances this technique will work with
any watch band like this one that's held
together by pins the first step is to
figure out which of the links are
removable and to do that you look on the
inside of the watch band look for little
tiny arrows pointing to the outside edge
those will tell you which pins are
removable and the arrow indicates where
you should start tapping if you don't
have a watch band tool kit like this one
you're going to have to balance the
watch against something soft like a
mouse pad or a cork board like I've got
here but this little yellow thing is
great because it will hold the watch
band vertically while you work on it
put the tool right on top of the pin and
then give it a couple whacks with a
hammer you'll need to remove two pins so
figure out how many links you want to
remove I'm going to remove just one in
this case so go down to the other end of
the link that you want to remove and
push that pin out to the hammer might
not knock the pin all the way out so
what you'll need to do is grab it with a
pair of needle nose pliers and pull the
pin all the way out once you've removed
the right number of links now comes the
tricky part putting it all back together
it's just the reverse of the way you
took it out make sure you've got it
lined up and then just tap it back in
hello little tight actually